it's time to babble with your host Kevin
Smith and Ralph Garman it is Saturday
night in Hollywood so let's babble the
[ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith the fat one and
I'm Ralph Garman the comfy one yeah
what's the stardate Ralph start at nine
seven do one football they're outside
the nimbus-7 welcome to Hollywood
babble-on ladies and gentlemen must be
Saturday night in Hollywood I just drove
past the Hollywood Bowl and there were
so much [ __ ] traffic tons of people
running around buses everywhere they
must have done a Star Wars event oh
that's right the music of Star Wars I
think they do [ __ ] at the Hollywood Bowl
out here like play John Williams music
and show Anthony Daniels narrate oh so
c-3po was there cuz they do all six
films I think the music of all six films
and he stands there Knight says then
I'll too and I was very scared
our kids like who the [ __ ] is that guy I
never saw him in the movie is he wedge
you know I saw kids right it was a
beautiful sight though all these kids
running up and down a Highland Avenue
it's kinda yeah it's got a Highland
right there by the Hollywood Bowl all
with [ __ ] lightsabers like smacking
at each other in the middle of the night
so I pull up to the light waiting to go
I look down to the left just a sea of
kids hitting each other with [ __ ]
lightsaber blades and I remember going
like younglings Ron Skywalker's going
apeshit well I think of when I see kids
with a little kids lightsabers that
whole scene in that last Star Wars movie
where dude comes into the church and
he's like click closes the door on the
blade and the kids are looking at him
like this he puts the blade down takes
this [ __ ] know each other you got to
make a foul movie even worse I've made a
better movie we got those kids got
lightsaber fight in the cafeteria story
yes in the middle of America somewhere a
high school these two high school kids
had a impromptu lightsaber duel in the
in the school cafeteria nobody was hurt
it resulted in it you know a standing
ovation
it was these two kids were about to
graduate and [ __ ] not anymore no [ __ ]
principal comes along he's just like I
don't like these Jedi's you eat Utah you
know and so all of a sudden he's my
partner's got 10 days suspension and
they weren't gonna be allowed to walk at
graduation for the stupid light saber
fight the good news though with enough
pressure there was a Facebook page let
him walk they were saying the evil and
powers crushed the principal said they
couldn't walk so they're gonna be able
to walk I just imagine the principal in
a big cloak behind a desk
you think the back go to the dark
alright uh hey it's it's almost Father's
Day you know Kevin yeah good people at
man great have the perfect Father's Day
gift if you haven't got one for your dad
yet if you haven't you're just a dick
yeah
this is the man great grill enhancement
system in the barbecue world and the
cutthroat devil-may-care barbecue world
Ralph the man great grill enhancement
system is the Liam Neeson's [ __ ] of
barbecue it's [ __ ] huge and listen to
this
it's pretty [ __ ] heavy to end some
girth oh yeah oh the ladies love the man
great yeah
and it comes buckets put that on the box
and if you if you order the man great
through our site we found out what that
site is yes it's mark it's good at the
smart cast calm babylon page and there's
a clickable ad right there man it's
cheap it's like 20 bucks for the grill
enhancement system is dire you get the
brush as well a brush to clean your
great yes and it's it makes it like a
professional steakhouse it keeps the
juices in the meat opposed to getting
burnt and dried out on the on the fire
it keeps the fire away from the meat
which keeps it nice and juicy and tender
keeps that [ __ ] luscious it does
uncut like a European [ __ ]
it's just $19.99 if you go to our site
and I don't think we're selling it very
well you know we need is man great
theater well we have been doing the man
great theater commercials for the past
couple weeks and we've had some requests
actually this week saying since it is
Father's Day I thought Indiana Jones and
his father Henry Jones
might want to go into manga a theater
try to sell the man great and he gave us
some suggestions for the titles either
Indiana Jones and the great of man or
Indiana Jones and the penitent man great
yes yeah I wonder what that would sound
wonder what it would man great it's uh
Julia Julia what are you getting me for
Father's Day I've been really busy
Jr you know I've spent my entire life
looking for the holy great something
that I can put on my barbecue and keep
my meat from drying out the holy great
is in there but you must go and get it
take these clues I've given you penitent
man the penetrate band the penitent
the penitent man deals before the
penitent man kneels from the penitent
man the penitent man nails the penitent
man kneels before God eminent well Nils
all right I got the man great I'll bring
it out now shall we can barbecue you
stupid [ __ ] I named the dog Indiana
credits see man well done well done
just like your meat will be on the man
great grill enhancement system good I've
been selling [ __ ] the man great grill
enhancement system these are the only
cats on the planet who have advertised
with me and Ralph here on Babylon
showing your love go buy a [ __ ] man
great so they'll leave us alone we love
it I use it I've actually used it now we
barbeque some [ __ ] Oh congratulations
it's awesome I've used it for a while it
works really well did you yeah really
yeah no look nobody's here really yeah
when they first signed up they sent me
why that's the right on the grill and
I've been using it for weeks I start
selling it willy-nilly without using it
I mean it could have exploded on a child
or something but turning my room's cloud
over your barbecue turns out it's pretty
good profits actually very good made in
America goddamn it there it is yes this
is the steel that won the war and beat
the Kaiser and then killed Hitler in the
bunkers yeah the man great killed Hitler
and his
patriotically won't happen to buy one
for dad and not just for dad sometimes
mom grills as well actually mom grills
that quite a bit at least in my house
all right let's give some shoutouts to
some folks who came from particularly
long distances or are celebrating
occasions we always love to thank them
from coming out here to the Jon Lovitz
podcast theatre starting with the Arthur
and Madison or Arthur and Madison in the
house Oh Madison wouldn't be more
apparent when up her face went down man
Ralph and Calvin my wife Madison and I
are huge fans of the show so we're
thinking of popping our HBO cherries for
our one-year anniversary Madison man
like the mermaid then Arthur could use I
figure I'd get more ass though if I took
her to a topless resort in Cabo so we're
coming two weeks after our anniversary
instead well done Arthur's smart of you
I'd really appreciate if you'd wish us
happy anniversary in your old timey
radio voice Arthur and Madison are three
Madison a two great Monica's and also
two great presidents Chester ray Arthur
and James Madison so happy anniversary
and god bless america
by the way ya didn't want to leave that
out
PS Kevin my wife thinks you're totally
hot oh no I'm sorry my wife thinks your
wife is totally hot yeah sorry I misread
that too well that's even easier to hook
up yeah see me after the show a
three-way with Kevin Smith this is from
Anthony is he here from the state of New
Jersey Wow right up front
welcome sir well the great state of New
Jersey no easy easy with the greatest
state good enough goddamn New Jerseyans
around here coming to Kevin's home state
of New Jersey flying out for work
managed to move my schedule around to be
near Los Angeles on Saturday just to see
the show wasn't sure if it was a good
idea potentially screw with my work
schedule but then I heard that garmi
t-shirts were on sale and a gaming
little extra push I needed to say the
hell with work well thank you sir thank
you for
coming here and buying one of those if
you haven't seen it or picked it up here
go grab yourself a garmi t-shirt before
you leave they might ask you for money
in fact they probably will but make sure
you they definitely will yeah make sure
you grab them where can they get one if
they're listening at home we're gonna
get the shirt we haven't put them on the
internet yet what they will do so stay
tuned or come out here to California
let's say you live in Iowa you want one
of these shirts here yeah take the trip
out get a shirt that's right bill and
Sue speaking of Jersey bill and Sue you
guys in the house there we go no more
Jersey folks right I'm traveling to
California from the finest state in the
Union New Jersey what is it with you
[ __ ] people I think New Jersey is so
great you ever been there
have I been there I grew up across the
river yeah no I've never been there yeah
you well enough to stay the [ __ ] out of
that stage just what we need more bad
drivers in California people coming from
Jersey driving around the Jersey driver
in Philadelphia that was a stuff of
legend we'd be driving down the freeway
and Philadelphia and somebody would cut
you up [ __ ] Jersey drivers in Jersey
we say that to hero bill and Sue are
celebrating their 20th wedding
anniversary oh yeah wait a second 20
years of being married how long were you
dating prior to that two years how long
into the two years were you [ __ ] he's
like two minutes look at the man totally
man so you guys been having sex for 22
years
let's see it's [ __ ] possible it works
man I've been banging the same chick 12
years 13 years now
it's possible how many light years
you've been having sex the same person
nine men amazing yeah like one day you
just stopped having sex with everyone
ounce or stop pretending you could ever
have sex and then just start having sex
one person like these two but do it for
22 [ __ ] years and they're so bored
with each other they come to this show
right we had a choice we could [ __ ] each
other again or we can go see a podcast
she's like if I have to eat your [ __ ]
one more time
I'm gonna shoot myself and not with your
dick let's go see Babylon yeah sorry you
came now aren't you bill and Sue happy
20th anniversary a lot of love in this
room today how about that 15th
anniversary for Gil and Dawn or Gillen
dawn in the house right here happy you
guys can sit together and then swap yeah
yes the banner bursaries yeah totally
anal bursaries they're here for their
50th anniversary they would love a shout
out as the penitent man Harrison Ford
well he's just selling man greats
earlier so he's already been burned
Kevin and Ralph me and two friends are
gonna be at your show John is a Babylon
virgin John and Cynthia you guys here
Johnson you know [ __ ] you them not
really right now though Cynthia did
right if you can convince Kevin to tell
us about his first [ __ ] experience I
will buy you a drink
did you tell a story recently to katie
morgan or something oh I blew myself
once I think that's what they were
talking right yeah when I was younger I
was way more nimble and [ __ ] and I spent
a couple days doing the you know it's
very very you gotta be careful I was
laying on my back on a bed and I kept
throwing my legs back over myself and
[ __ ] like that like a gymnast like I was
about to do a [ __ ] roll and Stan yeah
but it was a rolling sock I was I had to
rule it out make sure that like hey man
I might like it so I took a shot in the
mouth and I was like I don't know what I
would say after this
and that was my own so you know I was
like I guess I'm kind of a Cheetah Girls
guy or something like but I did it you
know you always think about like if I
could suck my dick I'd never leave the
house that's not true I know I'm gonna
be sorry that I'm asking this but did
you actually get your penis into your
mouth yeah yeah I didn't get like full
[ __ ] chefs I got that I was like Reed
Richards and [ __ ] like stuff it's just
unbelievable to think about now because
now I would like I've got this gut right
here it'd be like traversing [ __ ]
Africa to get to my dick but back then
it wasn't as bad and so you would get
like let's say that you know obviously
this is not to scale right but let's say
this was the dick like I would get to
the head and all you need is the head
that's where all the action as always
look good for neck action you know so I
got this right to the lips and tongue it
was pretty pathetic if you ever caught
me it would have been like I was always
terrified my mother would walk in and be
like oh my god but I did it anyway back
to the news yeah
well Cynthia didn't show up for that
story and I think she's she's sad now
take that one at home Freddie and Lara
from Mexico you guys here hey hey guys
how are you coming all the way from
Mexico I'd like to see your papers
please if you don't mind you going back
are you gonna stay all right okay
well we're going to go through your
luggage I hope you don't mind and the
speaking of traveling Josh and amber
here all the way from Guam if they made
it where you guys up here hey man
welcome guys where's Guam that's in the
great Pacific Ocean oh yeah
I was like where's the green to see I
say Oh mom
welcome welcome from mom what are you
doing Guam a brewery in Guam
right on man hello Guam beer all right I
wanted to read this email because I
thought it was so funny being a married
man like you are 20 years or so 20
[ __ ] years give it up one more time
for 20 years I wanted to read this email
from amber because you can just hear the
fight that's going to happen later
tonight because of this email okay my
fiance Josh and I are coming to the June
4th Joe all the way from Guam I drafted
you an email from us to get a shout-out
for traveling such a long way to see the
show but Josh thought it was too wordy
and he sent an email instead a few
minutes ago he told me he thought he
forgot to mention my name in the email
that he sent could you please give us a
shout out at the show I'm really looking
forward to seeing you and Kevin thanks
for all the laughs garmi strong in the
Pacific amber oh you know Josh got an
ass-full after this email was sent
oh so my email wasn't good enough but I
didn't even put my name in your email oh
the wedding is off that's what I'm
thinking happens in my house a spa means
a whole difference yeah I feel like why
is that bad we get emails from around
the world James
[Music]
Garland's got an email
[Applause]
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions yes
Robert Kelley my name is Chris Leland
I've listened to the show since the
beginning a while back I was listening
to your show in a long trip with my
ten-year-old son I thought he was
listening to his old music on the iPod
turns out he was secretly listening to
the show 10 years old those of you who
were following at home even though he is
way too long to be young to be listening
I decided to go ahead and let him listen
with me
I know it might be wrong No and that
might not might be wrong it's [ __ ]
wrong
who's Liam Neeson dad I'm sure I listen
to worse when I was his age and I turned
out just fine no you didn't you're a
shitty father anyway would blow his mind
if you gave him a shout-out on the show
sometime his name is Daniel Daniel call
the authorities
father is not a good person he's a huge
fan now so much so he's asked me about
renting Sharktopus Daniel by Sharktopus
don't rent it I get more money that way
thanks to you and Kevin have the great
shows don't forget to give that penis a
sandwich you're a horrible horrible
father sir hello Daniel welcome if
you're listening to the show let me tell
you about one sex this is a great email
I look forward to more from this
gentleman he did not sign it I think
you'll understand why when I read it
Ralph and Kevin I am currently
hitchhiking across the country using the
power of the internet to find places to
sleep and people to smoke weed with it's
the night of day one and I've already
smoked three times today with three
different people I am telling everyone
my name is Frank Garmin by the way I
will send you another email next week
because hopefully I'll be in the
audience on the 11th see you then no
signature what a surprise he's too
stoned to remember to sign his name
sometimes I don't like to write my name
that's right hey guys I recently came
across this lake and thought it was so
awesome the first thing I thought it was
you two doing Babylon from behind it
thanks for the podcast the eric mason on
twitter here is the picture of what he
found on the internet it is a desk made
of han Solo in carbonite I'll happily
invest in that how great is that it's
it's hand in the Carbonite with a glass
piece on top so you can sit behind it
and use it like a desk yeah imagine Han
Solo hanging on the wall instead they
just put legs under I'm in a little
glass piece over and you can eat on them
or it'd be about this size wouldn't I'm
telling you I I've had the life-size Han
Solo piece so it's it's basically all
they did was there some legs to it put
the glass on top so it would totally
work I'm just saying I'm right that'll
be for your one-year anniversary of
Babylon and I'll be like - the hot table
is that instead of the butt secks what
the tables over process I know Rob
McHale my name is Katie my boyfriend
Davis's birthday is coming up he's in
love with your podcast he's been asking
for anal for a while but I wanted to
wait until his birthday to give it to
him but he doesn't know that he's going
to get it so I thought it'd be awesome
if he were to find out he's getting anal
while listening to your podcast we get
to deliver the news oh my god man this
is tremendous what's her name her name
is Katie Katie whose name is Davis Davis
congratulations this is your you're
going where no man apparently has gone
before the balloon not I suggest they
both drink heavily misty you're not a
guy who drinks but you no no no and you
know what what's the same Davis Davis
don't be a [ __ ] hog Davis just you
don't have to go to the chef just the
head is fine [ __ ] that
I'm never [ __ ] you what you get
inside you know just go balls deep
that's what I say gusto
rights for the living Kevin Davis just
the head is fine bury that [ __ ] Davis to
the balls a tire board to your ass so
you don't fall in yes because he may
never get another shot
it would degrak be honest if you're a
dude you don't even have to go all the
way in just the thought of it press at
the front and that's it
save yourself a lot of misery and then
like 20 minutes later like I'm so sorry
about the such a pig I don't know what I
was thinking in that out goes smoking a
pipe but I say well it's wonderful for
you darling as it was for me I didn't
think of the snifter approach that's
right it would be great of Ozzy Osbourne
you give him the good news Katy adds
[Laughter]
Hollywood babble-on the only show where
they pat you on the back for anal this
show is really taking a strong anal
Benton a couple weeks where demystifying
we're taking the stink out of anal ralph
this may be my favorite email of the of
the week my name is Eddie long time
listening first time writing I am from
Bolivia do you know where is Bolivia he
knows he's not his first language so
let's not mock well I am writing this
mail to let you know that I used to
listen to your podcast to learn English
when I was studying I used to have the
hottest teacher ever I went to that
class only for her I don't want to
bother you with story but yes I [ __ ]
her the borat wrote in I make that
fantasy true and she wasn't drunk
please 5/5 between you two
[Music]
what you have to say about this keV
please Ralph could you say
congratulations in Arnold the Governator
voice well I will write soon thanks for
your show Eddie
Lenny write us every week like commanded
from Bolivia man I had lots of sex but
that is a story for any other time what
did bother you in a story
hello bother us we'd love to know the
details I make that fantasy true she
wasn't drunk between you two how it's
awesome man needs to be more that will
close every email with that please feel
free to high-five the nearest person and
the governador boys man oh I'm sorry
Eddie from Bolivia
ah and the enemy from Bolivia oh yeah I
think I used to have a housekeeper from
Bolivia yeah turns out that she was too
fertile and I have a lot of time alone
by myself just coming it's like pumping
you like pumping into a muscle coming
all the time I'm always coming now
mostly by myself and of my last email
the last email of the week
Ralf huge fan of the show when listening
since the beginning you guys make me
laugh harder than anyone else on a
weekly basis my favorite movie trilogy
of all time is back to the future and I
was [ __ ] around online the other day
when I came across this video I was
surprised that I had never seen it since
I consider myself a big fan of the
trilogy
anyways hoping you guys could shed some
light on what the [ __ ] is going on here
garmi strong Jake now I don't know if
anyone else has seen this on the on the
internet you can find it on youtube if
you just look up Back to the Future 3 it
is a scene from Back to the Future 3 the
last in the Back to the Future movies
remember when Doc Brown's on the train
with what'swhat's the woman's name the
actresses naming his wife Marisa Mary
Steenburgen and he's got the two kids
Jules and Verne and he's talking to
Elisabeth Shue and Michael J Fox and
they're talking it's the very end of the
film and in the background one of the
kids who plays his sons is going off
have you seen this
he's doing the weirdest [ __ ] and no one
caught it I guess and this is in the
actual film so I brought the clip in for
you to look at but I have no idea what's
going on he's sort of beckoning someone
to his [ __ ] and pointing to his penis
and he's gotta be five I'm assuming his
dad let him listen to our show it's the
only explanation I can come up with but
here's the video I was talking about
from Back to the Future three
of course it's the race
let's show it again Joan in slow-mo so
you can you can see exactly what we're
talking about but as this deliverance
looking kid here who's making the
Chester an important to his dick right
he's like yeah this is where I want you
right here right right there that's in a
movie
and I kind of pride myself on knowing
all those weird little moments in films
and stuff I never heard of that
that was quiet number down low well the
[ __ ] Doc Brown sitting there is
summing up the entire Back to the Future
series like the future is unwritten
mater you can do what everyone and the
kids over there going like [ __ ] you doc
come here to this little kid right here
talking to Einstein the dog or Elizabeth
Zoo I don't know who he's referencing
talking Elizabeth Shue Barney's gopher
is like come here here's the future the
future I'm huge baby Liam Neeson
do you know what he was doing though I
think he's basically you know it looked
like maybe that was a further take down
the road and the kid clearly knows that
that's when they push in so essentially
the kids sitting there going like okay
now is the time like he'd seen them do
it a few times so as he goes like this
that's when the dahle they dalian on
that shot so to me as a guy who's been
around film it says that's like six or
seven take and that kid was just like so
he's mimicking he knows exactly when
it's gonna move you see it in movies a
lot usually back in the 80s too if you
watched there's a scene in ET where
Henry Thomas is at the table where he's
telling the kids like shut up nobody go
out there and see Thomas how I think is
the kid who's sitting across me just see
the side of his face and he's literally
mimicking the dialogue so this Henry
Thomas goes nobody go out there see
Thomas how I think it is goes little
moments like that so basically it's like
you get kids on a set long enough and
they say watching it over and over again
you know they may forget especially he
was young yeah so he's doing this the
hand gesture means the cameras coming in
yes what is the pointing to his dick
gesture mean on a movie set DeMille on a
movie set when an actor points to their
car yes you know what that means
all right as we do every week we say
goodbye to some friends that entertained
us over the years with the Tinseltown
steps and now another edition of
they will be missed got a lot of emails
this week from Disney fans
apparently wall-e bog is no longer with
us or Wally Boag I guess his name was
pronounced he was pay us bill at the
Golden Horseshoe review in Walt Disney
Land in Disneyland the golden shoe one
more time the Golden Horseshoe review
aka the worst attraction at Disney the
one as a child you like no guy would
sing and make balloon animals and do
jokes and stuff for 27 years he did it
yeah he holds the record in the Guinness
Book of World Records for the most
numbers of theatrical presentations ever
performed by one performer performed it
over 40,000 times at Disneyland three
days three times a day five days a week
Wow yeah he got on he died at 90 years
old oh holy [ __ ]
well that's a big bucket of win but that
ride still sucks because it's not a ride
round no it's where adults go to drink
and kids alike can we go on the
submarines apparently loved him put him
in a couple of his movies and intended
to use him as the voice of Tigger in
Winnie the Pooh but then Disney died and
we gave the role to Paul Winchell hmm so
the first Tigger was him or he never we
never got he never got the gig cuz
Disney died before he got a chance how
pissed off was he by the way [ __ ]
Disney you know he's just shaking his
head I gotta go back to make balloon
animals in the park could have been
somebody yeah
any weird kid here's kids like can I
have a Tigger balloon he's like you [ __ ]
Steve Martin said he was the first
comedian ever seen live it had a big
influence on him as a kid oh really who
Steve Martin working this yeah he used
to do balloon stuff all the time the
cover of one of his albums he's wearing
like a balloon hat yeah I used to do
that as part of his act
Martin tweeted this week my hero the
first comedian I ever saw live my
influenced the man to whom I aspired has
passed on Wally Boag
about that so I mean big bucket a win
what a great life he had also passed
away this week dr. death Jack Kevorkian
died at 83 years old today I don't know
what they put him in the good or the bad
but I decided to put him into good I
honestly I don't I never understood why
people I don't think it was a bad guy I
think there's some people that want to
die and I'm trying to help them do that
peacefully and I think we should have
the right to die if we want to
especially if you like your life do with
others if you're in pain and your
suffering and stuff so he passed away
big bucket of death absolutely sorry
you're right big clarice taylor who
played Bill Cosby's mom on The Cosby
Show died at 93 years old hmm she died
her home in Englewood New Jersey she was
glad to go cuz she was in New Jersey
hate her that much or what man she
received Emmy nominations in 1986 she
and Earl Hyman who played his dad on
that show both received Emmy nominations
for their roles as Anna and Russell
Huxtable I always remember those
episodes they did one a year they do an
anniversary show for his grandparents
and then the Huxtable family would
always do some lip-synching to some
James Brown song or never remember that
I hated those [ __ ] episodes
and james arness actor best remembered
probably as marshal Matt Dillon on the
TV series Gunsmoke passed away this week
at the age of 88 years old he was it was
one of longest-running TV shows in
history 20 years it was on television
married as long as these two right he's
right it was the longest-running it's a
law-and-order
just beat it in 2010 but his role as
marshal Dillon was sort of the
quintessential cowboy role originally
John Wayne was put was asked to play the
role in television he passed but
suggested they talked to his buddy Jim
Arness for the role so it wasn't it
wasn't Jim Arness didn't he also play
the thing in the original the thing
original Howard Hawks movie the thing he
was the creature he was the catcher his
dad is that brother was Peter Graves
from the Mission Impossible Co that her
brothers you ever seen a grown man naked
okay
passed away this week from natural
causes apparently his friend and manager
said no diseases nothing untoward he
just got tired I guess
that's the way to go probably had his
boots on he had the the forethought to
write a letter to his fans on his
website before he passed away
get the [ __ ] pretty cool let me just
read you a little piece of it
had a wonderful life was so blessed with
so many loving people and great friends
the best part of my life was my family
oh stop it I'm gonna cry stop it we're
at a comedy show oh my god don't read a
dead man's letter stop this nice I know
but it's so luxury I'm gonna cry oh I
got to think about others yeah actually
my wife Janet Liam Neeson's do
in order to take this time to thank all
of you for the many years of being a fan
of Gunsmoke the thing how the West was
won and all the other projects I was
lucky enough to stop it James I had the
privilege of working with so many great
actors over the years I was honored to
have served in the Army for my country I
was at Anzio during World War two and it
makes you realize how very precious life
is thank you again for all the many
letters cards emails and gifts we've
received from you over the years
you are and always have been truly
appreciated sincerely Jim - move on
god that's [ __ ] beautiful man Sudeep
what a [ __ ] giver right up to the end
he was like you know I'm gonna write him
a letter as well
Wow that's [ __ ] here's a little piece
of Jim our nest from his classic role as
marshal Matt Dillon on Gunsmoke go get
butanol yes sir
you and I come off or close to the in
dead man marshal juggling you take bill
and you take the rest of your men and
you get out of Dodge get out of Dodge
he gave us get out of Dodge that's
another phrase that's where that came
from [ __ ]
Wow nothing else if he only gave us get
out of Dodge let's get out of Dodge
[Music]
years big bucket of wind that's
beautiful made you cry like a little
girl that's kind of that so [ __ ]
touch you ain't cry and I know we've
already talked about Lee and Leslie
Nielsen
Leslie Gill sister [ __ ] not as baby not
as big just watch it we talked about his
passing but just this week they showed a
they published a photograph of his
gravestone which I thought was great
because he always wanted the something
special put on his gravestone they
finally sent a picture of it so I wanted
to I wanted to put this up it says
Leslie Nielsen let her rip he said
because he loved fart jokes and so he
put that on his grapes no Hollywood
helpers in the news
mr. now this is a cheat it's not exactly
a Hollywood helper but it is a cool
story because we both love hockey it's a
hockey helper I know we love hockey and
we love show business and this combines
the two of them this week Bono found
himself caught on the side of the road
and it's not a bond of the Saints story
it's just bono trapped on the side of
the road in Vancouver hitching a ride
because he was caught in the rain Bono
story
so he's hitching a ride and he gets
picked up by Jill bear boule from the
Oilers yes and they had been tannoy lers
would you think I meant Doc Brown showed
up with the Train his kid was going like
this I jumped through time come back to
Houston he was very cool bono said of
Brule describing was a very modest man
apparently he asked where do you want to
go and bono said just take me where the
edge is
so he took him to a gay bar anyway at
the show in Edmonton that night bono
decided that he wanted to be Joubert
Brule said as much to the crowd and then
started naming who the members of his
band would be if they were hockey
players on the Oilers he said Larry
Bowen would be Mark Messier he said Adam
Clayton the basis would be Grant Fuhr
legendary goalie and the edge he's kind
of the great one bono said and he said
he would be Wayne Gretzky in the band so
he took this so - and he's Brule patient
yep a brutal I didn't play with them
snowy Gators before it's an all-time
list I guess so this story is about how
bono didn't know jack [ __ ] about hockey
yeah you're right sir uh it's like a
rugby fan but now he's interested in ice
hockey really gave me a [ __ ] ride
I'll watch his sport did you do a bow no
do you have a bow no I don't really know
because that's British and he's Irish so
that's wrong talk amongst yourselves
Irish he's work about it man
watch the process he's trying to find
the Leprechaun in his head so I really
don't like ice hockey but I'm looking
forward to watching more of it that
deserves a drink right there what do you
got you gotta say something like how can
how can we all sing when there's so much
suffering
how much chuckle you'll sing there's so
much so free in the world
now say in the name of love in the name
of love singing getting that pose he
does like this put a sign on my back
when I'm doing something he thinks he's
Bono
in theaters this weekend new releases
beautiful boy comes out Michael Sheen
and Maria Bello play parents who find
out that their college son has gone on a
killing spree and then killed himself at
college that's that's bad right that's
what that movies about yeah Kyle Gallner
by the way plays the Sun it's meatloaf
also stars in this film
yeah now name was Robert Paulson
beginners opens up this weekend you and
McGregor as a magnifies out his father
played by Christopher Plummer is game
comes out his father comes out before he
says a terminal illness and he also
comes out as a gay man okay that's a
surprise right
that's a Father's Day surprise you don't
look forward to dad here's the man great
what you suck [ __ ] all right guess
you've already got the great man man
great no love marriage and excuse me
love wedding and marriage Mandy Moore
stars in the film about a marriage
counselor who finds out her parents are
getting divorced James Brolin and Jane
Seymour play her parents
are we in the middle of the summer well
there is one movie that came out this
weekend you may want to talk about x-men
first class did you go I've been in
Boston filming a movie of my own so I
haven't had time really to go to the
movies yet tell us about that real quick
really quickly I was out of town all
week just till today actually for a film
called Ted written and directed by Seth
MacFarlane the man who gave us Family
Guy in American Dad Cleveland he is a
live-action r-rated comedy and it is
about a young boy who makes a wish on
Christmas Day that his teddy bear come
to life and be his best friend and the
bear does come to life and it does
become his best friend and then we flash
forward 30 years and they're still best
friends and now they just smoke dope on
a couch and watch television all day the
Bears hooch ruined his [ __ ] life it's
got no job and no real foreseeable
future and I play Mark Wahlberg's the
guy who was the best friends with the
bear and I play Mark's dad in flashback
in the first part of the film I'm not
mute I actually have lines this time
apparently Seth MacFarlane trust me with
dialogue that's all I know
dawn thing okay back to excellent first
class you didn't see you didn't get yes
no I did anybody see it anybody not like
it seem it what you didn't like it I
like it more lower less what which one
it's nothing all right someone else I'm
gonna like it what do you think awesome
well there it is
both sides more I'll answer off the
spectrum you tuned I bought tickets to
go see it this afternoon I bought a
ticket online for me and the kid and
when I drank Showtime the kid was just
like I don't you know I don't feel like
going out of the house and [ __ ] and so I
thought about going but I didn't want to
show up the two tickets because I
thought the people be like I knew it
yeah it is true too fat to film yeah but
I do plan on going they got 25 of my
dollars but I haven't seen it good so
they'll get a few more of my bugs they
owe you really I look forward to it
though man [ __ ] x-men during the
Cuban Missile Crisis it's amazing it
always worries me that when they start
mixing comic book stuff with true life
events why cuz it just it just pulls you
right out of it cuz you know the x-men
didn't keep us out of the Cuban Missile
Crisis so already I'm a right now I'm
one step removed from the storyline
that's what worries you I worry about
[ __ ] like home invasion
[Applause]
apparently her monetary unit went off
that's what she calls her vibrator no
she was wearing one of those anklets
because she's under home arrest and so
the cops show up in her house because it
goes off indicating that she is off
premises it shows up and according to
people responsible Lindsey's electronic
monitoring system went up on Monday a
representative from the company went to
her home the representative found
Lindsey was there and shot her dead
outside sometimes I just make up endings
from my own enjoyment
the equipment in fact was replaced so no
no really no good story ending although
it is interesting I enjoyed this story
that apparently a man called her agent
saying he represented Warner Brothers
and wanted to cast her in the new
Superman movie and they said well come
over and talk to Lindsay about it turns
out the guy was just a stalker who
scammed her people and just was arrested
on the way to Lindsay's house really
yeah on the way it's kind of funny
though yeah funny if he got through
Jersey Shore star Snooki in the news
apparently she hit a police car in
Florence Italy where they're currently
shooting so many weird things happen to
this little girl yeah here's a picture
of her after the accident apparently she
was in a neck brace
but then it turns out she was just doing
it as a gag and took it off so she's not
paralyzed or her thank God so
disappointing all the news this week no
one's actually getting hurt you Whitney
Houston says 30 days of rehab isn't
enough well 30 years of rehab wouldn't
be enough for you Whitney she's decided
that she after completing a 30-day
outpatient program she wants more rehab
so she's going to go back in for at
least another 30 days because this time
she really wants to stay clean
this time she means it Amy Winehouse
another hand left to rehab after just a
week that's my girl
she's touring Europe this summer she
says she's already raring to go she
doesn't need all that messy rehab no no
no no no Naomi Campbell is threatening
Cadbury chocolates with a lawsuit
let me saw this story or not it's
[ __ ] amazing there's an ad there was
an ad rather for a new chocolate bar
called the dairy milk bliss bar here is
the photo of the ad it says move on
Naomi there's a new diva in town it
shows the chocolate bar on a bed of
diamonds showing how luxurious and how
pampered this chocolate bar is well
Naomi says it's racist because she's
being described as a chocolate bar she
says I am shocked Naomi Campbell says
it's upsetting to be described as a
chocolate bar not just for me but for
all black people and all black woman her
mother said I'm deeply upset do these
people think they could insult black
people and we'll just take it this is
the 21st century not the 1950s shame on
Cadbury how do they even know they were
talking about Naomi Campbell it just
says Naomi up there well she's assuming
it's about her because she is the only
super model known as Naomi Naomi Watts
maybe they're talking about her I don't
know like if I saw that I'd just be
confused as it was this have to do with
me eating and getting fat if I eat this
chocolate well diamonds come out of my
butt it's a confusing ad to say the
least
Naomi spokesperson says racism in the
playground starts with black children
being called chocolate bars
Cadbury has since apologized for the ad
and has pulled it saying it will no
longer feature the ad
[Music]
who you shooting gents Cadbury okay
that's a little I don't know that's good
more confusing to me than anything else
obviously they're playing off of her
diva status of her hitting her
housekeeper with a phone and punching
cops and she's been in the in you know
trouble with the law a lot being a diva
and being a you know out of control
that's what I'm missing I don't even
know she's been busier oh yeah she's
very famous for being sort of a diva and
she actually did some time for hitting
her or assisting with a phone and she
beat up some cops at the Heathrow
Airport she said several run-ins with
the law being a diva I think that's what
they're playing off of I don't think
they're trying to call little black
children on the playground chocolate
bars if you if you hit a cop is that
diva-like behavior it's a bureau
supermodel so where do you imagine man
you get arrested and you're just
slapping cops and you're like I'm a diva
I I can't imagine anyone ever really
trying to be racist to a black child
calling them a chocolate bar though I
don't think I just never really come up
has it is that is that is that a well
known you oh when I was a young black
child well I mean it's hard because not
being black you don't know what grace is
and what isn't but it just seems that's
a stretch yeah yeah I think the ads are
stretch I did - that's admit was kind of
the first misstep so more racist showbiz
news apparently the Smurfs are racist a
new book has been published this week
called the little blue book by a French
sociologist an author named Antoine when
yo and he says that the Smurfs are and I
quote creatures living a mostly idyllic
existence packed with racial propaganda
and are embodied of a total totalitarian
utopia steeped in Stalinism and Nazism
he says Papa Smurf is a leader of the
village an authoritarian authoritarian
figure and their lack of private
property and collective style economy is
a clear nod to socialism
meanwhile their enemy seems Jewish
Gargamel
matches negative Jewish characters and
Smurfette
the only female in the village is a
vision of Aryan perfection now I thought
this was just [ __ ] why is the guy
taking apart a comic strip that's been
around since 1960 I guess 1958 is when I
started 1960 that their own comic strip
and then I saw this episode of Smurfs
which I thought maybe though gave me a
little bit more perspective yeah here's
Papa Smurf
maybe the guy's got something that's all
I'm saying
Bieber fever shows no sign of slowing
down it never will
Justin just nabbed a major milestone
this week 10 million followers on
Twitter calm yeah that's huge man they
followed what's-her-face first it was
Lady gaga like 2 weeks ago or something
handsome he's the king I've got
important [ __ ] to say what pubic hair
fever says he's blown away by the
support and the amount that he is
followed by the way is 333 times the
population of his hometown that's some
perspectives no wow that's cool good for
him a little Canadian kid is beloved
right now not good for Selena Gomez his
girlfriend apparently all those fans are
out for her blood they're dating oh it's
Lina and Justin Oh Kevin where you been
how did you see the Billboard Awards
where they're making out in the audience
then we thought he won an award she was
like kissing him right there on his his
hairless face really yeah how he's got a
hairy face but his face and hair look
how old he is 16 12 to 12 it's not 12
he's 69 816 really he's 17 17 and how
old is she she's like 18 19 years I was
just a believer test and you fail but
she is of age he is not of age so wait
she's over 21
no she's 18 oh and he said that's the
age of consent that's close enough
yeah it's not close enough in the eyes
of the law is that true like they suck
she goes to jail that ain't true it is
true it's statutory rape what if she
gives him a [ __ ]
statutory jerk what are they doing then
all this time just holding hands and
nuzzling noses and [ __ ] well I know as
she's getting her life threatened on
Twitter and Facebook threats this week
came to Selena stay away from Justin
pedophile
I was angry when I wrote that I think
it's true though I've seen Selena Gomez
driving a panel van around the
elementary school giving out pretzel
M&Ms from the back reading a trail to
like a futon mattress in the back of the
van can you help me get this chair into
the van
Oh way to shoot great big fat person oh
it's your Buffalo Bill
[Applause]
book says if Selena Gomez breaks Justin
Bieber's heart I will break her face I
wonder do you think like do you think
she really they must be the him do you
think he's has he come with her yeah you
think
photos of him on a yacht grabbing her
ass in a bikini I think he's he's well
beyond his years in terms of scoring
yes living the life man ahead million
followers he's [ __ ] flying jizz all
over her joy wait those balls drop he's
really gonna be in business man he's not
just gonna shooting blanks the minute
he's got something he's manufacturing
somebody's really gonna get busy
shooting blanks all right it's time to
spend some time the intersection of show
biz and crime our new segment is that
new I don't know I don't know but we
will by next week okay Ben Affleck's
movie the town inspires a real-life
crime but this was interesting remember
in that film they put on rubber nun
masks and robbed a bank in Palos Heights
Illinois and man and women wore rubber
nun masks and actually robbed a bank
here is a shot from the actual security
footage I'm not kidding
but look at that mask that's the one
from the town oh we should man yeah life
imitates art they jumped over the
counter with revolver and semi-automatic
pistol opened the
vault filled a duffle bag with cash and
took off in a tinted window Chevrolet
they got away with it - tinted windows
don't mean mean nothing they know who's
inside
[Music]
it's tricky - from Brampton back around
um at least at least they if you're
gonna imitate any Ben Affleck movie that
would be a good one at least it wasn't
like you know yes thank you very much
Jersey girl the gentleman stayed he
stole my blood row you saw it coming
though he's like Smith's gonna go for a
Jersey girl joke I'm waiting I'm waiting
there's a girl yes sir it's bad enough
that he made it can you at least have
the joke have some sympathy that was my
yearly Jersey girl joke Wow
let's [ __ ] I wonder how Ben feels
about that if I'm a filmmaker and
somebody was like robbed a bank just
like my characters I wondered how I'd
feel only we knew someone who knew him
okay let's call him up hey Ben fancy no
I'll do it but all you're here is hello
I'm like Ben it's Kevin click Jennifer
Joyner we come down here he'd kick his
ass if he called this late she doesn't
go for that [ __ ] Jamie Kennedy was
stopped in Vegas this week he was
handcuffed by security the cosmopolitan
casino after he got into a fight with
another man apparently a woman walked up
to Jamie and said she wanted to talk to
him about a career in comedy the
boyfriend didn't like her talking to
Jamie they started pushing each other
and security put them in handcuffs no
charges were filed because police said
it was almost impossible believe anyone
would ask Jamie Kennedy about comedy
so they let Jamie go you see it wasn't
that Jan saw Bob strike back he makes me
laugh he was he was funny in that movie
in that movie he was funny oh stop it I
never see Malibu's most wanted
I didn't say he was great didn't don't
make her and in movies this he's a nice
guy alright
he's from Philadelphia too I feel bad
feel bad pumpkin on the guy we're gonna
[ __ ] in his mouth dude give him a
cheesesteak instead
Steve Martin was wrapped up in a crime
this week I thought it was pretty
interesting he was a victim of a German
art forgery ring that doesn't happen
very often it's a bad week for Martin he
lost his [ __ ] whole Disneyland is
getting screwed over in the art world
Steve bought a painting for $850,000 in
2004 called landscape with horses by
Heinrich camp and dunk he sold it in
2006 for a loss but apparently the
painting was a fake and now the woman
who bought it is upset with Martin
because it was a fake
he claims he had no idea it was a fake
when he bought it and police apparently
say it was the work of a German art
forgery ring who has been selling fake
paintings for some time and bilking a
lot of art collectors out of a lot of
money now Steve Martin known as a pretty
high-end art collector knows a lot about
art here is the photo of the picture the
actual photograph of the picture this is
called landscape with horses it's an
impressionist piece by Heinrich camp and
dunk now I don't know art but I've seen
the forgery and let's put the two
side-by-side I think Steve should have
known better because I certainly would
have been able to tell the difference
between the actual painting and the one
here but seems inappropriate I would
know I'm not an art guy but I would look
at that site this doesn't seem to be the
real painting the the suck it made it
did you have to apologize to the woman
he did he said he feels horrible he had
no idea that it was a fake so I imagine
he would have been like well excuse me
that's for the people who were born in
the 70s sorry I don't even see that
coming you set yourself up and I can
smell that's my I do I had to do it
before he did it over there I normally
have to contend with the quick garment
tonight if that dude of just like Han
[ __ ] Solo
[Applause]
Estela warrant we talked about her last
week she got caught by the cops after
she hit three cars on a drunken bender
and her Prius shouldn't that escaped
well first she beat up the cops who were
trying to arrest her then they got her
into the police station she got out of
her handcuffs and bolted out the back
door and escaped but they did announce
this week that she will not be
prosecuted on felony escape charges
because she hadn't actually been booked
before she made her break for it so if
you try to escape before they book you
apparently it's not escape good to know
man yes thank you uh Stella Warren just
you taking a leisurely stroll out of the
police precinct I'm gonna get some fresh
air gentlemen but you're ready to book
me I'll be in the parking lot and the
biggest story the week by far in my
personal opinion is the fact that Emma
Stone is a redhead again
[Applause]
big story
let's throw up that graphic shall we
here she is oh yeah she's back blonde on
the right
it's back to being red on the left she
was at a screening of her new movie the
help and it certainly helps me what I'm
saying I'm saying Smitty right down here
like little boy and back to the future
that's right
[Music]
congratulations Emma we will have you on
the show sometime soon I know we will
see I'm going away for how long am i
away from two weeks yeah next week this
time unfortunately I won't be here I'm
gonna be out in New York doing a
screening of Valley Girl with Martha
Coolidge and Deborah form and the valley
girl so what I'm doing concentred why so
soon just caught up with a mouth it just
saw a great movie ah but I'm doing that
and then the week after I have to go out
to Italy for a red state Film Festival
thing so I won't be here for two weeks
for alpha beer and I know the first
guest host is Johnny will be a guest
hosting next week and we're also trying
to get a very funny young lady named a
Catherine reitman to do the show with me
I've been a fan for a while now she is
the daughter of Ivan Reitman who gave us
of course
ghostbusters sister Jason sister of
Jason yeah so we're trying to get her on
the show too so she might do it in two
weeks and then you're coming back and
then all summer long we'll be here a
little beer let's talk about celebrity
relationships shall we ellen barkin this
one blew me away this week this was
something else Ellen Barkin who you may
know from well she's got a shitload of
movies she did a movie called diner that
was her first big breakthrough Barry
Levinson the director gave her that role
no 30 years ago he cast her in diner
gave her her big break now she is a new
connection with Barry Levinson she is
living with his 26 year old son
[Music]
Sam Levenson she is 57 years old he is
26
work it girl said the gay gentleman here
said RuPaul in the second floor thank
you so much
who says work it girl snaps up except
for Right Said Fred and RuPaul the only
people I can think of this is she's got
this to about 31 years yeah now if this
was a male female we've had been
reversed
would we be even blinking an eye I would
still I think that's not like I'm
judging it but I'm like wow that's
noticeable Barry Levenson feel though I
know like think about it when they were
shoot and [ __ ] diner this kid was
living in the director's balls while he
was directed and [ __ ] Ellen Barkin
and it was almost be as if like one day
she was looking at his balls going I
want to marry you one day just as balls
about him what if I don't know 15 years
from now
Harley starts dating muse I'm just
saying would they make you feel a little
weird that is I believe me that's the
thought that wakes me up in the middle
of the night at all times Jennifer's
that go back to sleep it's not happening
it's not happening Alec Baldwin's got a
new girlfriend now here's what I'm
talking about Alec Baldwin is 53 years
old yeah he's dating a nubile 28 years
old who just graduated from NYU oh well
that's fine that's what a stretch I
don't know I mean again I'm not judging
but how do you [ __ ] have a
conversation with somebody who wasn't
like there for all the [ __ ] that was
your formative experiences look guys
like us so much of our conversation
comes you don't think what you don't
think you're knocking no no that's true
aren't you the two from Mexico
yeah you waited the whole night to pipe
up and be like they aren't talking
they're [ __ ] nah
there is so much singing going on with
us - you big fat idiot they are Pocky
he has 53 but he sells a [ __ ] of a 27
year old man she is something but it's
one receptacle for him nothing's coming
out of her mouth his [ __ ] is going into
it they are [ __ ] what a sexy accent
she was as odd yes I have to stop well
done sir really good for you I can see
why you live down there in Mexico that
in the beheadings that's another reason
I'd go down I've never seen a beheading
before I'd like to check one out what's
down there
don't you even watch CNN or anything no
beheadings up here well the night is
young
Sean Penn and Scarlett Johansson
apparently they've broken it he seemed
like such a fun guy that yeah with I'm
surprised was she married to the green
lantern they broke up a while ago you're
gonna have to stay current son Wow all
right so she went after they broke up
with a green lantern she went dating
Sean Penn she's starting Spicoli do I
need to talk to about everybody
everybody like characters yes McCully
dated the Black Widow okay and then the
Green Lantern was like oh I'm so sad I'm
going to oh ah and then he laughs then
Harvey Milk and Ghost World
yeah a ghost world started living
together and now they broke up a pair
it's so strange when famous people start
[ __ ] I know you it seems like it's
very incestuous that whole world seems
like they only [ __ ] each other good like
Gwyneth Paltrow and Chris Martin from
Coldplay yeah they just put an ad out in
the paper apparently looking for a tutor
for their children Apple and Moses
but it gets better they're looking for
someone who will teach their children
ancient Greek and Latin well that'll
come in [ __ ] handy because River
trapped in the TARDIS with dr. [ __ ]
who and they have to save the people of
Pompeii because the lavas are coming
exterminate exterminate quick use your
Greek diamond egg yeah dead languages
man they want to teach the kids of dead
languages yes they have too much [ __ ]
money that's right if you know how to
play tennis and sail that's a bonus
they're looking to pay the tutor ninety
eight thousand dollars a year that's
what they're offering is they you know I
will learn to do all those things for
98k holy [ __ ] yeah could you imagine if
I showed up and was like no seriously I
want to do this yeah I learned Latin for
a little bit when I was kid Catholic
school days to teach Latin back in the
olden times
Oh cuz they used to the priests would do
the math Latin Serbs yeah oh yeah that
[ __ ] spiritu - oh that was my money - I
know yeah yeah my mom always used to say
she's ekam Spiritu tuo which I guess is
Latin for something one of the Catholic
prayers and I would say what is that and
she goes that's the Pope's telephone
number it's like don't lie to me [ __ ] I
was eight yeah whoever said that reckon
bit means are you sleeping I think
really yeah sing it like brother Joe
that's where is who where say dead
raccoon bit one time to go very very
drunk
oh speaking of being angry and drunk
it's time for the town let's cut update
Kevin and now for this week's countless
fun update we take you to the route
garner realm thank you David
this week's town let's count update is
about Chelsea Handler's new TV series
are you there vodka it's me Chelsea
where Chelsea is too old and hideous to
play herself Loren pre-fund who is
considerably more talented and
attractive will actually play Chelsea
Handler but The Hollywood Reporter says
that the role of Chelsea's aunt will be
played by Roseanne Roseanne Barr yeah
[ __ ] watching that oh stop it I love
roses
why do you love everyone who's bad and
hideous oh she's awesome man horrible oh
you're right look is where I draw the
line man I'm walking off this show no I
love Roseanne the sitcom I think it was
one really it's very well done feel like
at the ambush she won the lottery the
whole thing was a [ __ ] fantasy did
you like that no but I'm sure she didn't
like Jersey girls or even you know it's
like every once in a while somebody
makes something on like but I bat shows
[ __ ] brilliant and she just wrote a
fantastic [ __ ] article I think it was
in New York Magazine where she you know
talked about how Charlie Sheen his
[ __ ] losing his mind a little bit and
she says look I've been there yeah a
little bit she goes I've been there and
here's my perspective and it was kind of
a look back at her show and she tells
the story about how for the first year
is [ __ ] it's a fascinating read she
tells the story about the first season
of the show it was her act
everything was predicated on her
stand-up right and stories from her and
her husband and her sister she got set
up with a creator of the show I think
his name was Matt Williams he went on to
do home improvements and stuff right she
watches the pilot for the show at the
stage like you know they have a little
party first time they do the pilot and
in the credits Matt Williams is the
creator and she has no credit whatsoever
in the everything was hers and she went
to like Marcy Carsey who I guess was
running Carson Warner at the time was
just like you told me like this was
gonna be a woman show my name's not even
on it man like there's a dude's name on
it and the chick was just like oh you're
gonna ruin everything if you open your
mouth and [ __ ] and she was she taught in
this article it's fascinating she talks
about from that moment forward she kept
the
list on the door behind in her in her
dressing room where she was like
everybody she was gonna fire the moment
the show got to number one all the
people that tried to adversely affect it
and make it [ __ ] seems healthy
it's [ __ ] you could do the same thing
there's a list upstairs I've seen your
list that but it was it was a shame they
didn't give her a check for that show
though right she didn't get she can paid
millions and millions of dollars later
on but her point was this the show that
they were building was not the show that
she knew would connect with America like
they kept trying to put her in like
Peggy Bundy kind of clothing and [ __ ]
she was like that's not real like ice
one wear flannel and [ __ ] and they would
force her into outfits and she would
just come and bring her own clothes from
home and then finally they set her up
like the bruisers the producers bunk or
whatever the where the writers room was
and you know because she wouldn't wear
the outfit she went up she found out
there's this woman executive producer
who was like just ignore her and make
her wear our clothes and she went up
there with a scissor and she planned the
clothes the door and she was like [ __ ]
I will cut you and she says and then I
hung it there for about two minutes to
make sure she knew I was serious just
quietly with a [ __ ] scissor at her
throat because and her philosophy I love
this article so much her philosophy was
this she cared more than anybody else
she's like I'm gonna win because I care
the most like these people don't give a
[ __ ] about the show they just want to
make their [ __ ] money move on she's
like that this show is important and
she's like I'm gonna I'm gonna just care
more than anybody else and she
eventually won she got that dude kicked
off of her show she never got the credit
for creative I couldn't do that but she
took over her own [ __ ] show and as an
artist it's inspiring it's a good
[ __ ] read good reads all right I'm a
fan I like I think she's ballsy and I
love that show that I mean you're right
by Season nine it was a little [ __ ]
weird but eight years prior to that that
was a beautiful snapshot of American
life that was the perfect Americans she
had the creative wherewithal to bring
Tom Arnold on board so at least we had
that going for but he's even funny on
that show that show works man it's it's
it's it's a beautiful piece of
television speaking of TV shows that
don't work
Chelsea Handler has announced that she
may be leaving her popular show Chelsea
Lately because they are currently in
negotiations her contracts over in 2012
and she says and I kid you
I want to utilize my brain I want to do
something that's more mindful and isn't
celebrity centered so she may be leaving
her show because she feels that she's
got more to give I can't keep doing the
same thing my brain is bleeding oh I
wish if a is the show I'm going to do
but it's going to change you may turn
out that I'm done with it forever
apparently she has bigger plans I want
to do something for people that they
aren't expecting from me I want to
educate people and deliver news well
after all she is the Mort Sahl of our
generation she is she is the Lenny Bruce
Mort Sahl is the George Karl that you
won for with this audience man Mort Sahl
although I do have to give her credit
where it belongs she was on the cover of
Hamptons magazine this week and have you
saw the cover of Hamptons it comes out
of New York here's a picture of her on
the cover she looks pretty good
pretty good on the cover gotta give her
that and here she is at the the party
celebrating the cover of the magazine
oh wow still beautiful whoa she I wonder
if she means if I had to theorize she
said a couple bestsellers now so you
know she spent a bunch of plates oh it's
not just the TV show but if I had to
read into that there's been talk about
her moving up Network taking over one of
the big [ __ ] late-night shows so
maybe that's what this is about
well she wants to use her brain Kevin
she's got a lot she wants to teach us
you know that she wants to educate us
about yeah photoshopping apparently is
what she wants to educate us about
luckily she's not your Lex Luthor he is
I'm not her Superman but she's
more TV news Jane Lynch has been given
the call to host the 63rd Primetime Emmy
Awards this year talented ladies he's
very entertaining
hopefully Christopher Guest movies
especially she's like was the dog movie
Best in Show holy [ __ ] she's really
funny enough it wasn't one about the
movie the movie they made to the
low-budget film for your consideration
yeah it was great in that the poram they
made the movie about porn and she was
also in in which we call the one that
I'm a mighty wind my yeah very very
talent were there and they talked about
the religion where they like worship
color and she's good
while we're talking about the Emmys
people are already campaigning for Emmy
Awards I thought this was very funny my
buddy Jimmy Kimmel was in the news this
week along with pee-wee Herman he may
not remember when the Oscar nominations
were going on last year when people were
campaigning for Oscar Awards Melissa Leo
from the fighter put her own ads out
there in the trade papers trying to get
people to vote for her because she
thought she was underrepresented by the
press and she won then she won with
these ads
Jimmy Kimmel and pee-wee Herman how are
taking spoofs on her as to try to get
any attention for their shot at getting
an Emmy Award as well pee-wee Herman
spoofed one of her ads I got a photo
here of the ad and and this is Melissa
that here that's P way over there in the
same mink coat by the pool asking people
to consider for him and Jimmy Kimmel
also decided to spoof one of Melissa's
ads of Melissa dressed in a low-cut
black dress Jimmy thought he tried the
same tack to see if people would vote
for him for the Emmy so we'll see what
happens there should we take a look at
geek news [ __ ] yes who's one of our
favorite parts of the show James
[Music]
[Applause]
The Dark Knight Rises is still a few
years away one year it's one year away
coming next summer I've got the states
marked on my calendar man I can't wait
last Christopher Nolan Batman movie but
they're already ramping up the viral
publicity campaign we saw that photo of
Bane two weeks ago and now videos have
hit the Internet one video features what
looks like Arkham Asylum with the
chanting going on people marching in the
background very disturbing image and
another one even more disturbing because
looks like Anthony Michael Hall is
working again yeah he plays a Gotham
City reporter papers and the last one he
was in Dark Knight has the Mike
something the the anchor I'm GCM here's
the video that hit the web this week
about the Dark Knight Rises
[Music]
[Music]
it's Redrum Redrum
run they debunked that pretty quickly
who debunked it online that's not real
no no from over is if anyone else got
that not real not real yeah I saw him
and I was like one crazy well oh my god
Dark Knight footage fat fat fat fat fat
and it's not real after I came I found
out it wasn't real well none of this
afterwards that's all totally I was just
like oh yeah it's not real it's fan-made
stuff well good on them I know it looks
pretty good excited yeah me too
wonder should hire them speaking of DC
Comics they are rebooting everything in
the comic book world yeah starting from
scratch with all their characters yeah
maybe time for me to say goodbye really
is that work well it seems like this is
the point where they want you to say
hello because now starting with number
what they want me to say goodbye really
that do stop you stop reading for the
most part right just under GE comics
I've stopped
Kawai own a comic book store so I
technically I get new comics every week
but I don't read the actual comic so
I'll reach a paperback collections and
stuff like that but the actual issues no
so I understand like look there's some
people who've been like talking about
you know they have a collecting Superman
since issue 400 they're up to like 900
or something now but that's all gonna
dial back to everybody's going back to
one yeah so some cats you know a
longtime readers like what the [ __ ]
here's the thing that I I think I
understand I just want to confirm though
I believe they're rebooting or
restarting every story too so they are
like they're just not just the numbers
they're going back to they're gonna redo
the origins and the story and everything
that's going on with a Batman one will
include the death of his parents and all
that kinda stuff
yeah yeah I mean look their philosophy
is this right now
comic books are enjoying the most
attention they've had from the
mainstream like ever they make movies of
them now these movies aren't comic books
used to exist they're in a little pocket
world where the funny books and they're
great for keeping licenses alive and
making and you know lunchboxes and [ __ ]
like that but now they're big money man
now it's just like you can make billions
of dollars and and every like a DC or a
Marvel has thousands of
possible licenses every character is a
potential movie lunchbox something like
that so it's big money now so now
they're treating a lot more seriously
yeah they look at music news we were
just talking about this guy last week
Chet haze is his name he he's the son of
Tom Hanks his name is Chester Hanks and
he went to you Northwestern University
and he became a rapper named Chet haze
and he put out a song that we made fun
up a couple months ago and that's what
led us to our first rap battle or he
used Tom Hanks movie names to to rap
against each other well he's got a new
single out I thought it was important
that we hear it because it's [ __ ]
horrible
it's called another chance and I just
thought it was important that everyone
listened to it so you know not what to
get the next time you're downloading
music here's Chet haze
[Music]
[Music]
it is your mistake sir it is absolutely
keep looking keep you looking tip-top
while we pop a few buttholes no I wish
that would be clever assist few bottles
bottles yeah after she had me at
butthole yeah I like how he rhymed again
in the first line with again in the
second line he's got a gift he's a
master all right let's move on one of
our favorite times of the show where we
talk about how big Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how big it is for those of you
who are new listeners to Hollywood
babble-on Kevin Smith is fascinated with
the size girth length of Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] ever since I saw it you wish you
had seen it I know really the legend is
he's got the biggest dick in Hollywood
not that he is the biggest dick he's the
nicest guy in Hollywood well that's got
a huge kind of play this dude's carrying
a whole extra human between his legs is
though is the word so we started talking
about the size of it and one of our
listeners John McGuire in Glasgow who is
of course in AG army based there in the
UK he started Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
tumblr.com where you've been collecting
all the Liam Neeson [ __ ] jokes for the
past couple months and every week we
take a look at our favorite new ones
from the tumblr so here's this week's
list Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
when he went to the clinic for a burning
sensation the doctor revealed that it
was just Pinocchio trying to get out
inside the will Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big it shakes him after he pisses wait a
minute [ __ ] is so big in Venice he's his
own gondolier well that's big Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big there is an
intermission between his orgasm and his
ejaculation you go out get something to
eat get something to drink
come back in for the second act Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big a group of
Chinese carry it over their heads and
through the streets to celebrate their
new year Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he
doesn't shoot semen he shoots spaceman
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big women refer
to it as the Kobayashi Maru the
lose-lose situation Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that it simultaneously played
Jean Valjean both on Broadway and
off-broadway Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big Marlee Matlin can hear it coming
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
Chilean miners have been stuck inside it
for months and they like it there Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that Kevin
should probably see a behavioral
psychologist about it his semi obsessive
relationship is really disturbing
seriously you need help man
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that only
the penitent man shall pass Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that Pooh and
his friends call it the Hundred Acre
Wood Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big his
mother walked with a wheelbarrow in her
last trimester Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big all of his booty calls are
long-distance Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big Michael Bay directs his home sex
videos Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Malcolm X said we didn't land on Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] landed
on us Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big when
it hits the floor it sounds like Kevin
dropping the man great Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that in order to fool its
Archana arch enemies it puts on classes
each morning it becomes miss pepper
Gomez a young spunky reporter with a
nose for news and a penchant for trouble
only at Lisa's [ __ ] is so big George of
the jungle keeps slamming into it Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that if you get
thrown off while riding it a clown jumps
in front of it to keep it distracted
while you escape and Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big hipsters no longer like it but
still applauded its earlier work that is
Hollywood babble-on
for this week when gentlemen go out get
yourself some man great ass
till next week or well till a few weeks
from now I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph
Garman babble the [ __ ] off good night
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies you gentlemen give it up one more
time for Kevin Smith in the lab garment
[Music]